purpose of that text message was not to
show whether or not lauren canarac had
actually been asked to leave the
property or not it obviously goes to the
defendant was not looking to get rid of
her because he was not in fear he did
not have a reasonable belief that he had
to act in self-defense so that text
message goes to show his state of mind
it is not offered i recognize it came in
that way but it's not offered to show
whether or not she was actually told
because her state of mind
whether she was actually told or not
has no relevance really or bearing on
his guilt or not guilt
judges that's not the impression that
was created with that text that i
objected to
the the says official the jury has the
impression that up until right before
the shooting no one ever told counteract
to leave and that's a conversation they
had with my client and i can't put my
client on
you can i can't
you choose not to that's that's up to
you so don't say you can't put them on
you can't letting that text then judge
it creates a prejudicial impression that
barristone basically was sitting on his
hands which again falls into the line of
what the prosecutor was saying that he
wasn't afraid
and she was told by different people
you know that barista i know but but but
here's the thing
her state of mind
counteract state of mind whether that's
not really an issue it's it's mr
barrett's own state of mind
i'm talking about mary haskins gray
judge when she if you want to ask her if
she asks miss cataract to leave you can
do that that's her testimony she did it
she can tell you about it when it
happened where it happened what the
reaction was but can she also explain
judge that that word with regards to a
fish official that she was aware that
other people no
all right
because how does she how does she get
that information from other people
michael it doesn't matter it's still
hearsay
if you want to call other people in to
testify about it then call other people
you can't bring out your whole case
through one witness and say well it's
other people it's inappropriate you
can't cross-examine that
you want to bring in a meeting that she
wasn't even attending that's complete
i'm not going to allow it
i can ask this witness if she did and
when she did it in the circumstances
that much all out
but not other people
be back at
120 so we can start at 1 30.
you